[Musik]
hallo leute ich jetzt wieder arme und
ich habe euch eis mitgebracht
haben diesen fall für dieses video
selbst gebastelt er hat so viel spaß
gemacht auf calls oder in amor der gott
der liebe
das auf volllast von meinem fall auf
gleich verliebt ihr euch mitgebracht und
zwar den adventskalender den premium
adventskalender ich darf ihn heute
ausparken den festhalten
dieses video ist gespeichert und jetzt
alle dieses video ist gesperrt
endlich lange habe ich darauf gewartet
es an zu können ist der berühmt
berüchtigte eis premium adventskalender
es gibt einmal die premium-variante und
deluxe deluxe adventskalender ein
warenwert von 600 euro und kostet nur 69
euro 99 und der premium adventskalender
das weiß ich natürlich alles auswendig
ein warenwert von 900 euro und kostet
139 99 ist das nicht klappt ja wohl
diese diese herz dinge ich muss so tief
sitzen damit ihr die burg noch sehen
könnte um die stirn nicht oder hatte ich
mir überlegt dass ich mich jetzt aber
verkleiden möchte hatte ich irgendwie
das nicht so ein korb
aber ich bin sehr zufrieden und jetzt
darf aber ein paar tütchen aufmachen
allerdings nur sieben jahren trage ich
natürlich hinaus aber ihr sollt in
diesem fall nicht gespoilert wäre und
ich finde sie hinauf machen hat auch
besonderen reiz weil dann kann ich über
die einzelnen sachen mehr sagen als bei
24 türchen ruhig um für jedes türchen
und 30 sekunden habe deswegen let's go
erstmal zum design des adventskalenders
wunderschöne hellblau rottöne mit silber
und ein bisschen gold sehr weihnachtlich
und wenn man ihn auf macht dann ist es
ein wiederverwendbare regisseur kann man
ihn dann privat büffeln was ja immer
tolle gerade weil auch so
adventskalender ja auch was kosten oder
die bastelarbeit möchte man sich sparen
das ist ganz wunderbar sieht halt sehr
neutral aus das ist halt gut weil also
das ist kein logo darauf fallen wir an
mit türchen nummer 1 ach so für den
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass sie reisen
nicht kennt eins.de verkauft spielsachen
für erwachsene
also
was ist natürlich eine martens trend
hier nummer eins ein natural massageöl
winterzauber bericht jetzt auch so nach
zimt hochwertiges massageöl für
gefühlvolle anwendungen das finde ich ja
persönlich ganz gut
ich werde gerne massiert fangen ganz oft
an leute ganz oft mit massageöl dazu
jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr verlosen
aber ich brauchte ehrlich gesagt massage
oder
[Musik]
auch doch es hat arid denn zitrone ist
auf jeden fall auch so ist so ein
zünftiger duft würde ich schon sagen wir
können zum glänzen kann man natürlich
auch als normales öl verwenden wir
gleich mal eine kleine handmassage die
männer sagen eigentlich schon besser sie
bekommt nur wer sich so zwischendurch
mal die hand muss ihnen ist auch nicht
schlecht oder andere körperstellen aber
das überlasse ich eurer fantasie
wo wir jetzt aber auch so auf die
weihnachtszeit zu gehen kleiner tipp am
rande passagen schenken und jetzt nicht
nur die super teuren 50 euro massagen im
studio denn ihr seid die sind super aber
die kann man sich nicht immer leisten
und man scheint sich das gegenseitig
also ich sag mal so über eine halb sie
die professionelle massage von meinem
freund als gar keine massagen bin ich
ehrlich als nächstes muss natürlich der
sechs gekommen nikolaus gleich möchte
sehen was hier an nickel aus drin vor
der diensten richtig
2006 sommer
hahahahaha
nicht wahr
falls ihr das nicht kennt sie schon mal
da steht ist feier
so schaue ich immer wenn mich das
überraschen ich kenne das war ja
eigentlich gesagt bis jetzt nur als das
gerät was ich auch schon mal auf club
nach gemacht habe falls ihr dieses
ticket nicht verstanden habt hier ist es
reden wir erst mal über das design das
ist wunderbar design ihre dynamisch ich
glaube hier ist viel arbeit und liebe
rein gesteckt worden um dann viel liebe
und arbeit woanders reinzustecken
[Musik]
die nicht auch eine wilde party mal
gelernt habe zwölf jahren elf wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie sich das anfühlt und
das direkt gleich auszuprobieren packt
eure an die nasenspitze
er hat sehr viele stufen
[Applaus]
ich würde behaupten 20 pferdestärken
da ist die thermometer drauf warum ist
ein thermometer drauf
ok mit dem an und ausschaltknopf macht
man halt
die ganzen stufen dann haben wir
verstanden ist aber noch so ein thema
mieter selbst feiert klinik mit das
innovative talent überzeugt mit seiner
modernen handy app steuerung das ding
kann sich mit der sense for connected
verbinden und man kann es tatsächlich
auf 39 grad erwehren macht mit dieser
information was ihr wollt ich finde es
ist rundum gelungen
doch mit zum nächsten
hiermit aber auch langsam warm das
nächste türchen ist natürlich meine
lieblingszahl die nummer 9 1 auf
heizbare vibrator ich komme darüber noch
nicht hin wechseln was ist denn er
neulich werde mich freuen also schon mal
schön weihnachtlich ist design auf der
verpackung man fühlt sich schon richtig
in weihnachtsstimmung ich bin gespannt
was drin ist
ja klar der riesige schnell senken das
ist natürlich ein vielseitig
einsetzbares seil damit kann man zb
geschenke verpacken immer mal wieder
oder man verpackt sich selber oder
seinen partnern schenkt sich gegenseitig
jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ich gehe
also nicht so spontan sehe würde ich
sagen das ist von ordentliches bondage
sei da hat ein bisschen houdini zu hause
spielen und ich befreie mich
ein need to know what is ist
gerade 25 meter
ich würde schon mal gerne einfach mal
versuchen das selber nachzumachen ich
weiß nicht ob es jetzt so mein ding wäre
aber trifft die shades of grace sie
warum das ist aber ich finde zum
beispiel ist drückt nicht auf der hand
also auch wenn ich das so richtig eng
machen blut staut sich zwar ein bisschen
aber schon angenehm auftakt kann man
kommt zu einem kleinen waldstück nicht
letzten sie letztens einen tick tock
gesehen wo dann eine so ganz schnell so
sich selber gebündelt stadt hat man das
so ich weiß es nicht aber die jahre wird
weil youtube gemacht und dann war sie
halt gebunden und ihre nächste
glückszahl ist die nummer
17 also ich muss sagen also man kann
diesen adventskalender sich bestimmt
auch selber schenken bzw den von einer
freundin kriege aber ich habe irgendwie
das gefühl das ist so eine perfekte
pärchen adventskalender man dann so
natürlich die zeit ein bisschen
aufregend gestalten kann die
weihnachtszeit da ist man ja eh schon
aufgeregt weil weihnachten vor der tür
steht und dann
noch ein bisschen mehr auf
die guten kirchen auf machen ja schon
mal voraus gesucht welche tür nicht
aufmachen darf und ich glaube sie
so wieder etwas von zs feier ein
überraschungsei also es ist ein massaker
exakte also würde man gar nicht wissen
was man hier bekommen also
was ist das
mein gott es hat so eine lustige
konsistenz ich weiß nicht ob es das ist
so ein bisschen möglich wie sie gekocht
jetzt verstehe ich das
natürlich klar weil dieser rennkalender
für pärchen es für sie und ihn für alle
alle dürfen mal
also das hat ja noch und wenn man das so
umstellt sieht man das hat sorgen so
noch dran ich als frau wirst jetzt nicht
viel damit anzufangen außer meinen
finger reinzustecken aber da wurde mal
das ist was für das anders ich es mal
vorsichtig wieder eindruck kann mich ja
weniger geboten
im moment bin ich realisiere was ist
denn mit seinen stimulation snabe und
dem flexiblen anschmiegsamen material
beschwert derzeit ist von massive attack
babbel momente der absolute ekstase der
das material ist besonders den war
wodurch sie sich sowohl die eigene als
auch der gesamte vielen dank der
innovativen hydro innen sind keinerlei
gleitmittel ich ein wenig wasser
ausreichend
also das ist das ist jetzt hier für die
männliche fraktion macht kommen wir zu
türchen nummer 20
0 triptis so penthouse all i want for
christmas steht drauf als arbeits aber
gespannt ich glaube
[Musik]
das ist wie eine strumpfhose von
material für den ganzen körper
und hier noch nicht rum positiv
willkommen ich bin gespannt was sagt
kann mir das gar nicht vor wie das ist
wegen ganzen
ich würde aber auch sie darauf wieso
christi ich bin seit cool weil ich
glaube nicht dass wir nicht so im laden
wäre oder online dass ich sorge zutrauen
würde das zu bestellen weil ich keine
ahnung zu schüchtern bin oder zu nervös
vor sowas jetzt wo ich das hier habe ich
eindeutig zu sein wäre es natürlich
jetzt nicht anprobieren und wir machen
weiter mit türchen nummer 21 aber dass
anni das hast du mit absicht ausgesetzt
aufmachen das hat ihr gefallen an ihr
ich ziehe das für dich an machen wir
gleich weiter mit tüchern 21
pia was von sandfire ist es so krass
japan ist auch einfach fan von chf 1
gegen wolfsburg
sonnenbrille ist es nicht auch wenn es
gut zu meinem kostüm passt muss gerade
recht positiv erwähnen dass ich glaube
ich hab schon ein auf ladekabel bekommen
jetzt ist da nicht noch eins dabei was
ich sehr glücklich finde weil das nervt
nicht so hart immer diese 100 auf
ladekabel zu hause im winter
für solche schrecken war ein bisschen
loch in der mitte
[Musik]
das ratespiel gilt auch nichts für euch
los was könnte es sein also ich denke
man kann es sich in irgendwelche
hoffnungen reinschieben auf jeden fall
aber was ist dieser tour ist mit dem
loch in der mitte nicht verstehst und
entriss mit dem loch in der mitte ist es
ist der star des fire lolli plaques 12
motoren versorgen den
vibrator klar natürlich in dem weiß die
diamant förmige struktur des platz
stimuliert zusätzlich eine breite basis
und softe citigo und sorgen für ein
sicheres und hingebungsvoll klar
echtzeit und schmal kommt er daher
[Musik]
doch gleich session noch kommt ganz
schön lang
ist das normal weiß nicht ob es okay ist
aber ich konnte den also ich kann den so
so
also so kuckuck
[Musik]
unsere do it yourself ist und leider
sind die jetzt schon beim 24 türchen
angekommen ist es heiligabend die wachen
auf wahrscheinlich eine tolle nacht
letzte nacht weil wir schon 23 türen
aufgemacht haben und da gehen wir zum
kalender und dann packen wir aus vielen
jahre garantie für die produkte
und nicht nur das wenn ihr das bereits
de gestellt habt ihr auch 365 tage 365
tage rückgaberecht ihr das produkt noch
nicht geöffnet hat und weil ich zu
dieser zeit so gerne adventskalender
verlose hat mir als de erlaubt 3 glücks
adventskalender an euch zu verlosen auch
instagram dafür bist du jetzt nur
übergehen die teilnahmebedingungen
findet ihr unter dem post also der post
online das gewinnspiel geht los und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel glück und jetzt
machen wir mit dem
weiter und jetzt könnte ich mir schon
vorstellen was drin ist hier steht wie
das fire drauf
ist der
[Musik]
heute guckt
sieht ja schön aus jetzt kommen noch mal
zu meinem tik tok
essence feier saugt nämlich an deiner
tores ich hatte eine phase in der die
welt ist hat das feuer
eingedrungen bin und ich habe auf partys
so vielen leuten erzählt dass ich dieses
ding jetzt haben es ist so ist man ja
als frau generell sagen könnte ja frauen
kriegen wie schwertern orgasmus was ja
auch nicht so ganz stimmt es geht nur
darum wie wir das machen sich gerade zu
den leuten die nicht so schnell einen
bekommen haben beziehungsweise auch nie
so richtig wusste ob ich über einen
hatte oder also ja und dann hatte ich
das ausprobiert und dann wusste ich was
orgasmen sind ja jetzt weiß ich das ganz
gut ja also
hier feiere ich bin wirklich so
überrascht was man alles in diesem
adventskalender bekommt für 139 euro 900
euro warenwert das ist crazy das
überhaupt möglich ist weil diese
produkte wirklich sehr hochwertig sind
und wenn man sie alle einzeln kaufen
würde würde man so viel mehr bezahlen
auch bei dem deluxe adventskalender 69
99 bekommt meine 600 euro waren wer das
ist einfach drauf und lohnt sich glaube
ich extrem also wenn ihr euer repertoire
doch aufbauen wollen was spielsachen
fürs schlafzimmer angeht dann ja wohl
durch den adventskalender ansonsten
sehen wir uns beim nächsten video wieder
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen am ohr
geht jetzt durch die stadt erstmal
seinen pfeil suchen und dann
das ist doch kein werbevideo wenn ich
nehme einen rabattcode für ich habe
die tore gemacht die leute seien
rabattcode hatten ja irgendwie einen
rabattcode aber mittlerweile war ja ich
das total wenn ich das kaufen möchte
oder ob es einen rabatt code von
jemandem wird oder wenn man den
rabattcode hatte lenken jetzt wäre die
chance also leute jetzt ist die chance
ich habe einen rabattcode über 40
prozent als auch der heißt nein wandel
40 unterstrich rat k21 events 121 x 140
unterstrich ak 21 damit kommt ihr 40
prozent rabatt und ist es gültig auf
alles außer bücher hages tipp als aktion
gekennzeichnete artikel und den kalender
selbst bis zum 24 12 20 21 sorry das ist
leider nicht mit drin aber das ganze
ding ist schon ein ersparnis also viel
spaß beim schaffen hier unten kommt ihr
zum leben zu eis de und der viel spaß
beim gewinnspiel und wir sehen uns jetzt
wirklich das nächste mal bis dahin
sollte bleibt frisch und ich jetzt
schneiden dieses video was ich jetzt
natürlich schneiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]